yeah yeah we just uh jumped straight
into it we have a lot of shots yeah
oh not as hard as holding your mom
though
you don't know that you don't know that
my mom is a beautiful woman how to eat
would you would you describe your
mother's heart no okay and then we i
guess i guess it's souls then
all right let's see what others i mean i
mean i i believe we're going right out
of the gate with our hot take of the
year because here's here's the thing
right i don't know what counts as like a
hot take is it like a bad take or
controversial take
i think it's a bit of both you know yeah
if you have a take that 95 people
disagree with yeah that could get you in
the hot tape category yeah all right i
think if you're also just a bad take
right
you know i'm sure when uh
uh whenever they figured out the earth
was flat i'm sure that was a hot take at
the time actually it's a bad take just
normally you mean when they figured out
the world around you is a hot take just
not a bad take with reasons
if you think about it listen that's all
that's all hot taking people have been
shunned in the past and then they turned
out to be right so a hot take doesn't
mean you're right it just means you're
going against the consensus let's see
what the nominations are yeah 90 of
bread tastes the same that's uh that's a
gauntlet okay i have to ask do you stand
by this statement to this day um
what did i say in the episode i can't
remember the general sentiment of this
take the take do you stand by it i can't
uh
i don't believe all bread tastes the
same but ninety percent but yes there's
ten percent that tastes different right
so i because i believe okay here's the
thing i remember the argument we had was
because connor was saying i would eat
bread as a main course and i was like i
can't eat bread as a main course i need
a supplement with the bread in order to
enjoy it right it's a nice snack but
it's like not a meal you know
um and that's where that's where i
let out this outrageous line and then
another food take here from connor this
time food poisoning is not an illness do
you stand by that absolutely i think it
was a case of i think it was a case of
good art good point terrible execution
on my part which is connor syndrome at
this point yeah this is like an actual
like valid take that i just described so
poorly that people don't want to agree
with right and then on the subreddit and
twitter and stuff people have to fix my
explanation
so that that off i mean that's the fixed
explanation with all i still stand by
this this general sentiment is still you
know okay and then uh one from me this
time jesus christ was okay it's really
that outrageous
i mean i don't think it was but i hope
this one wins
i really really want to just say
someone's okay to win of the year kind
of agrees
like out of everything here is like we
have some outrageous takes but like i
want that one to wait just because
just to be like shonen fans will be like
partake of the year 90 percent read of
what is all the same this is not the
only time when shonen fans are actually
going to come together to like cooperate
on something i really hope so don't stop
right there because the next one is 86
was bad by me
i stand by that obviously some of them
are animated
this was the one of the biggest
meltdowns i'd ever seen from a trash
taste episode people lost their [ __ ]
when i said this yeah they all were in
like in tears it reminded me that our
trash taste episode uh our trash tastes
viewers were also anime fans which i
always forgot for the longest time yeah
i i forgot for the longest time i forgot
like like us people here watched anime
at one point in their lives you know and
uh they're very passionate what i hate
about when i have a take about anime i'm
sure you guys can relate to this is that
no matter what how much i watch or what
i say there's always some justification
as to why i'm wrong i feel like it's not
just anime it's just whenever you watch
something in general yeah like
like you and like doctor strange
what do you mean you you haven't paid uh
fifteen dollars for a disney plus
subscription and watch nine hours worth
of sub content and i'm sorry that you
don't understand doctor strange too
after watching only doctor strange one
it's like what's wrong with you marvel
fans okay uh i'm sure that'll be in the
next year's awards yeah but yeah this
was one where i said i watched nine
episodes and apparently that wasn't
enough to form an opinion apparently no
of course um because i stand by my
takeaway
it's like judging one piece and stopping
at episode 100 you know like how how
that is
after all the times you hear it gets
good at episode 800.
you did it you didn't listen to them
you guys can enjoy the shows i just
don't enjoy it that's it get over it all
right dan who won this who won this one
all right please jesus christ and win i
just wanted
the winner it better be bread it better
be [ __ ] take of the year goes to
90 of bread tastes the same
[Applause]
you know what iron man god damn it iron
man
yes anime takes a valley thank you
are you saying that you think that
jiu-jitsu is just okay
do you want to know how many percent uh
how much percentage of the vote your hot
take got i want to guess that he got
like 60 to 70 percent of the vote yeah
well he got 66.9 percent of the vote so
apparently a lot of people thought his
take was back
all of europe came together
no no the entire german population
joined in to vote
what are the rest uh in second place was
you connor with food poisoning is not an
illness with twenty twenty point four
percent of the world wow barely any for
the other animators yeah what were the
other ones uh jiu-jitsu kaiser was okay
came in third with seven point six
percent of the vote oh and uh connor's
second take was the last with five point
one see everyone only five percent of
people agree with everyone agrees with
us
yeah just because one one means that the
others are right right that's that's how
the trash awards work right that's never
worked i've been liberated i've been
exonerated
it wasn't a hot take it was a good day
how do you how do you feel about that
guy
um i mean i wanted another one to win
yeah that's probably one of my worst
takes i've ever said on traffic it is
literally the take that always gets
quoted yeah yeah if you want to
discredit god it'll be like god said
this anime is bad yeah but he shouldn't
like like
like i'll be like i'll defend [ __ ]
pizza crust or like not eating pizza
crust until the day i die i'm proud of
that [ __ ] i'm just like okay that's
that's that's not my best moment you
know yeah
that's like my dark that's like my dark
past i like try to get rid of man
oh good start good start all right the
next category
next category is the best out of context
clip i swear to god there's nobody last
year was it bang bang bang one no it oh
yeah it was better
yeah yeah
my favorite
used to this day so it's gonna be hard
to see what can top this yeah like what
could top it what could top this what
are the nominees that is sad this is a
good one
you go through about 20 emotions in five
seconds what was like what was going
through it
i like i look at that i and i i list i
listen back to the conversation that uh
that this happened in i'm like
i don't know it wasn't a sad question it
wasn't even a sorry moment
it was just like it was it's like the
instant sad face for like just a second
and then like snap it was like a snap
back to reality moment right
i still want to know what was going
through your head i don't know i would
pay so much money to figure out what was
happening
so much money all right and then tits
out for the boys and then before you
know it
it's like there's like 15 kayaks like 30
boys in this bank just all going kids
out for the boys to sell for the boys
sure you're being misogynistic i'm so
happy this became a thing
yeah we definitely made anything after
the trash taste uh charities charity
stream yeah it did it did some good
because we've got yeah wallets out of
the boys we made it wholesome guys yeah
we made it wholesome somehow and then of
course it's the this is from the stream
yeah yeah
clip
accordingly
[Music]
we were supposed to not laugh but
apparently uh it wasn't hard
like i almost laughed looking at us
reacting to it right because
like i wasn't laughing at the clip i was
just like i i was like dead like dead
face and i saw us just like i saw this
out of context clip live and i'm just
like yo it's [ __ ] hilarious man
that's [ __ ] hilarious though i'd like
to think that this person submitted it
like as a joke but i don't think they
did yeah i think that was serious
unfortunately i just like this is the
such like the best like you got the
whole squad laughing like just clip i've
ever seen in my life right
and then next touching anime figures
blindfolded yep what the [ __ ] yeah it's
huge there's a lot of bits and bobs
hanging off it
[Music]
oh my god oh my god it just keeps going
i know right [ __ ] i know exactly what
you're talking about holy [ __ ] i can't
see but i know exactly where you're
talking holy [ __ ] this just keeps going
i finally have gaunt we're glad i don't
know what this is yeah i don't know this
one either so i guess let's have a look
yeah i would be i would gladly be racist
[Music]
all right well there we go what was the
context why did you say that i guess
that's a good out-of-context clip
that's so good out of context because i
don't know the context when would i say
that why would i say that was it like
towards kids
no i don't know what it was but like
just the poise you said it in is like i
would gladly be racist like you're like
standing up for something you're really
believing
do you have like a split personality and
like the like the second gun is just
like really racist or something
i think i think you were saying you
would gladly be racist towards wasps oh
that was awesome
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right well
who the winner is yeah i want to know i
have no idea with this one i really want
the sakura miko to win yeah i want the
sucker yeah i feel like i know each
one's going to win yeah
all right
if i was a betting man gone is sad
really right right yeah yeah that's a
really good one as well the winner is
drumroll please
would gladly be racist what
i mean to be fair it is amazing out of
court that ain't me that ain't me
that ain't my man
that me that ain't my hands
god would indeed gladly be racist what
was the percentage that it won by this
was really close oh yeah
uh god would gladly be racist one with
31.9 percent of the vote okay
second place is god is sad
it's 31.1 oh one percent difference
kant is just the best out of context the
only one that can beat me is me he's an
out-of-context machine right here yeah
he's a two-time winner
uh tits out for the boys came in third
with nineteen point eight percent i'll
tell you that i'll say that
uh touching anime figures blindfolded
came in fourth with 11.5 so sad
sacramento came last yeah right
sacramento came in fifth with four point
three percent of the vote so sad so
can't win come on
yeah no yeah sacramento came in last i
don't know why there's two that was a
bad these are all banks they're all
bankers
still holds the title the two-time
champion
someone please take it from me i don't
want this anymore i don't want this
anymore